this is the explosive talent which made
amy tinkler one of britain's greatest
ever gymnasts
but behind the flawless routines
exhaustive work and an olympic bronze
medal
tinkler says she was the victim of fat
shaming and bullying
i would give up that medal to not have
gone through what i did
which is really sad um
obviously getting an olympic medal is
like
it's not a normal thing not many people
can say they've got an olympic medal and
the fact that i'd just rather not have
that to have gone through
what i went to it's really sad tinkler's
the highest profile yet of dozens of
gymnasts to speak out about a corrosive
culture in british gymnastics
the sports head coach amanda redding has
stepped aside because of the bullying
claims
tinkler says reading and culling still
another senior coach
would regularly embarrass athletes about
their weight i got food poisoning
real bad and i am
i was in hospital overnight and
i came back into gym into little shore
when i was feeling better
and amanda basically turned around and
was like any excuse not to train
and colin said well at least you'll have
lost weight now
try not to put it back on after i'd
literally been
sick for 24 hours with food poisoning
i was praised for that colin still says
he doesn't recall or have record of
making the comments both he and amanda
redding say they'll fully support an
independent investigation
into these abuse allegations at british
gymnastics which is ongoing
but tinkler says some are still scared
to speak out
no one in british gymnastics anyone
feels comfortable going to
and in most personal clubs you don't
even feel comfortable going to your
personal coaches
so until that changes and until
coaches national coaches directors
ceos become approachable and
are willing to learn willing to change
and willing to listen
then nothing's going to happen british
gymnastics said in a statement the
incidents recounted by amy are
completely unacceptable in our sport
investigations are already underway into
a number of these claims
with their stars turning against them
the governing body is under increasing
pressure to place athlete welfare
at the heart of its future martha
kellner sky news